Let's uh get back to Discord
davidpackman.com Discord we are taking
calls for the week and seeing what's on
people's minds let's go
um why don't we go next to Derek from
Orange County Derek what's going on hi
David I had a quick question about
um generally how you see the Maga GOP
and feel free to reframe the question if
it's a little too convoluted for you
okay
um I just wanted to ask how you see this
current iteration of the Maga GOP do you
see it as a logical conclusion of the
modern GOP as though they're leaving
behind folks like Romney Liz Cheney were
were their politics like a necessary
conclusion to our logical conclusion to
what we're seeing now with the current
manga GOP listen I don't know about
logical conclusion but there is a
Continuum and I talked about this
earlier in the week where this all go
the the modern Maga GOP
is the conclusion let's wait on logical
but it's the conclusion to
Civil Rights era starts upsetting 1950s
conservatives who feel as though uh
minorities are starting to get too many
rights and too entitled or whatever
leads to Reagan
uh and anti-welfare sentiment and some
kind of like meme politics leads to the
Gingrich takeover a speaker of the house
in 94 and radicalization of the party
Clinton derangement syndrome during the
kenstar Lewinsky investigation dum dum
George W bush that ushered in kind of
just a lot of non-thinking people into
the party
Obama which coalesced a bunch of racists
into the party and conspiracy theorists
and then Trump was sort of like the
final layer so far like there will be
more layers as time goes forward so
whether it's logical I don't know but
it's been a steady 50-year decline so in
that sense it's not completely
unpredictable I guess I would say
yeah I mean I'm pretty pretty kind of
new to in terms of like paying attention
to politics I would say ever since I
guess Trump but I feel like for some
reason when the sentiment of like not
really accepting election results
doesn't feel too new to me but it's
definitely a lot more prevalent in this
current political climate right now
absolutely I don't know if you agree
with that yeah I agree with that I
completely agree with that yeah it's
become you know it's the overt nature
and Brazen nature of if we win it was
fair but if we lost it was rigged that
is that that feels new and different
yeah yeah for sure yeah well thank you
so much for taking my call I really
appreciate you summarizing that very
clearly for me I appreciate the
opportunity to do so very much thank you
for the call the David packman shows
longest running sponsor is blinkist the
app that takes thousands of non-fiction
books boils each of them down into an
explainer you can read or listen to in
15 minutes blinkist also condenses
episodes of popular podcasts into
15-minute explainers I've been using
blinkist for years to supplement the
books I read I love reading I I read all
the time but there's even more books I
don't have time to read and you can
often find those non-fiction books on
blinkist and consume the entire thing in
15 minutes my favorite new feature on
the app is blinkist connect which lets
you share your blinkist premium account
with someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users I have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist Sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to Robert Greene's the 48 Laws of Power
the new version Robert Greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com
davidpackman the link is down below